the UI while you see behind me
represents everything that we're
interested in Android design all aspects
of a touch and visual experience we want
android design to be a platform for all
of the incredible innovation of Google
all the powerful new groundbreaking
features that are changing the way we
interact with the world having computers
that recognize your face that understand
what you say all of these things will be
embodied in the future versions of
Android but we've added some really
really awesome features to Ice Cream
Sandwich just to really help everyone
use their phone and dog being is a
really easy way to share information so
if I'm looking at a web page on my phone
and you want to read the same page maybe
it's a great story in a magazine touch
the two phones together tap the screen
and the content goes straight across we
use beam to transfer files from a remote
desktop to another NFC capable device so
if you're sharing the file with a friend
you can just beam it to them and they
can download it ice cream sandwich is
really nice the user interface is very
slick it's fast it's responsive and it's
it's very well developed for us beam is
great it allows us to make a quick
makeshift group so we just take two
phones tap them together and now they're
sharing with each other so if you're at
the mall or skiing or whatever it is you
do where you might have to split up for
a while and then come back together it's
a great way to just stay in touch Google
created Android Beam to make it really
easy to share content but it's a
platform thing it's for developers to
use and to have their own use cases NFC
can be used for so much more you can
just exchange information over
beam is all about getting information
from one device to another in the
simplest way for small it's one click we
could make it any easier than that
really really cool you should check it
out
you